she's gonna reach a point where no
matter what to say her 16 your eyes have
seen more than you'll ever know she's
gonna tell you she has the world figured
out hello I'm Barbara Harris I've been a
father for approximately 30 years five
children it has up down I'm training for
the world that's the bag that was
started so that when you have a question
that no one particular voice dominates
that mainstream on a conversation access
to different fathers in ways they
believe that their children should be
brought up may be another tool that you
can place in your toolbox that can help
you along the way today I'll be taking
questions from three young fathers and
giving them some advice from an old
father like themselves and like they say
in that hour if you're not careful you
might just learn something before this
is all over
hey what's up my name is Kier I've been
a father for two and a half years now my
daughter Emery will be three so she's a
superstar she don't even know it man you
know I did this conversation I really
hope to get an idea of how a man who was
once my age and then my predicament kind
of navigated through that difficult
situation and he came on I want peace
cuz I don't know how to do that I'm iffy
and I'm the father of Naomi a four year
old I have a dad and he's you know side
coaching me already but it's it's always
good to for me I believe to get some
advice and information for someone who
really doesn't know you who doesn't have
all this bias that's coming from you
getting ready for this call with mr.
Harris I'm excited man cuz I got so many
questions I'm a father of a
nine-year-old y'all know Lynn we did a
couple videos together but a man she's
about to be a preteen so I know it's
about to get real so I'm really looking
forward to talking to him seeing what
insights he gave me
so you have kids that are like all
different ages infancy toddlerhood
adolescents teenagers a dope like which
stage was your favorite like why did you
love that stage adolescence I think
that's the time that I love the most
because now you letting them go they're
going to school now they're just
starting school and they're just oh the
world is starting to open up a little
more and they're telling you their
friends they're meeting about it you
know you gotta let them go to somebody's
house that's the best part
and I think that's my favorite part
because now I'm 50 I'll be 55 in August
and when I dream now and out my kids are
my dreams they're that age there are
seven eight nine you know so but about
that before if they like frozen in time
maybe your dream in that state is worth
doing and I think that's because that's
the state that I really thought was the
most amazing so what you're basically
saying is my best days are yet to come
me and my daughter's mom we're not
together at the moment so I'm thinking
about like I'm getting older now
starting that kind of traditional family
where my new person will be in the house
and I have five kids run around or
something like that
with you having a household full of kids
because it's what 70 yards total like I
could do like a pickup basketball game
like I got stubs and everything how did
you kind of handle a household my oldest
son is from my first marriage when I was
in the Marine Corps then I got married
again and when me and my wife start
having my other my first my first
daughter the first thing we did was but
my son came into the house from
sometimes some people your family you
know the cousins and all that oh that's
your step
I said no he's not a stepbrother he's
your brother don't put nothing between
you and your brother and from there
about how do you keep the household
together without losing your head your
mind
everybody has responsibilities everybody
has a chore and everybody has to see
love they have to see discipline they
have to see that they are expected to
rebook stick but they expect to see you
readable and give yourself some time
every night mean I grandma watching
hockey watchable bases grandma's big
grandma and I didn't good auntie you
know say don't don't let no don't see no
children don't see no gyms so houses
they're gonna ruin so I was wondering
what was a moment in your daughter's
youth that you wish you cherished more
something that you think that you know
you're like watch out for that cuz it's
gonna be you know that moment well my
oldest daughter I would say when we
first put her in t-ball and I was one of
the coaches and I watched her just for
for five son like that and her the kids
were sitting on the ground
picking daisies and throwing dirt on
each other's hair and you just let what
we be it was and I didn't know it till
later on what we did his parents were
was we got in the middle of just kids
being kids they were at a place where
they were there to play and they were
playing how kids played but we were
gonna tell them know you're gonna play
this way this is how yeah but if I
already just relaxed and and not been so
you know every time she got back on the
dirt I pick her back up and you know can
I shoulda did that you know I'm so if I
could go back those are things I would
cherish more I had a chance to whole
dating thing like I'm crazy I'm crazy at
least I think I'm crazy because I'm my
head I'm like no nobody is good enough
for my daughter
nobody's gonna date my kid y'all just
gonna be in this house level one big
happy family right I know that's not
realistic but let me cook in terms of
data in like how do you sit realistic
expectation is like for yourself she's
gonna grow into a beautiful young woman
on her way getting there she's gonna be
a beautiful girl and God is gonna be
attracted toward but you but being
arrived and we'll who
the plan okay what do we think is the
appropriate age for her to interact as
far as you know talking to boys you know
when that level comes when I when our
daughters were old enough to - we're
mature enough we had conversations with
we didn't just a lot of a school to have
the birds and the bees conversation
little bee and we didn't wait for
somebody think in the street or they
friends - tell him the birds and the
bees cuz you wait for a little Paula Tom
the birds of the bead you don't know
exactly what he telling them and why he
tongue exactly and then the way she
watches you interact with mom yeah
that's gonna be key she's gonna sleep
over a child should see mom and dad
disagree
a child is see an army just like they
need to see love they need to know how
to arch because if they don't know how
to argue when I say argue that means
constructively disagree and be able to
disagree and go to the fact that hey
let's go to bed we ain't gettin over
this one going to bed he stood together
if she can't see that well he can't see
that what happens is somebody's gonna
show up how to argue they go this how I
suppose it's on TV somebody said that
this stuff especially plaques is
probably supposed to do this
that's the hi-hat so then he has to be
loving and he says you know the whole
thing
I'm seeing a lot of constant just attack
attack attack especially on like the
black man so a little bit about me I'm
originally from New Jersey so I'm kind
of moving to LA chasing the dream I'm
raising the daughter and then it's like
I also have to leave my house and deal
with just America on their own they're
both getting for lack of a better term
and it's kind of frustrating sometimes
when I see that I had to fight all these
individual battles so a lot of times it
come it gets overwhelming so when I
think of you know five kids and coming
home I'm like I would love that if I
lived in a sitcom but with the America
that I know I don't even know if I want
that you know I mean and I kind of
started getting into my head about it
remember this you're not gonna change
the fact you're black we're trying to
change the fact that how America sees us
but you're not gonna change the fact
you're black you're not gonna change the
fact you have black kids and we are
unapologetic that they're gonna be
beautiful and they're gonna be rock
stars and they're gonna show up and
they're gonna show out because we're
gonna put the work in but we also have
to remember that we have to give up hope
because right now a child watching
what's happening on TV see my children a
little older but still I have to give
them hope I have to tell them I remember
what I started from I remember the
incidents that happened to me and I
remember did not take all that Whitney
the scars my ancestor carried the scars
for me just told me remember that I took
this star for you because the minute we
let somebody defeat us you know it's
over this is just the way it's gonna
always be then we lost you said you were
with your damn right it wasn't a
household he was America Bobby was about
right and I'm like I always tried to
separate it like when you got your
father in the house and he's active
father in the house but he's not active
at all which I recently learned is
almost as bad if not worse in some cases
not having a father at all and then you
have not having a dad at all so you got
those you got these men that come from
these three different family structures
like for the guys who either had a kind
of night their dad or no dad at all like
what advice would you give them like
just to keep their head on straight you
know what I'm saying to persevere
through
learning how to be a dad learn how to be
a man learn how to be a partner like
what advice would you give her like a
quick attire put your pinky go number
one don't lie to yourself and be
truthful that means that if you have a
dad in the house and you got no the
difference
I got a dad you know okay what was dad
in the house doing what did he do like I
was diagnosed with no child or alcoholic
there was trauma in the house you
understand but to get past that you have
to admit there was trauma in the house
that you have to admit that that changed
some of the way you think you thought so
before you can eat that you got to
understand the maybe there's a sickness
you don't have a father in the house
it's something your father not being
there causes you to have some kind of
sickness you don't say so now you got a
kid if you look around and you gotta
keep and you only keep your an Xbox
you're on the PlayStation and your kid
is miles away and you and they seen that
kid in six months you got a problem but
if you don't have mix you got a problem
you can't fix number two you have to
find some way to love your son
I don't care who you are you don't love
you you're not gonna love that child
away that child needs to be loved and
you definitely love though the woman
don't know man the way they want to be
lucky if you don't love yourself then
number three you have to break that
cycle if you find yourself in a cycle
where you're doing the same things that
granddad being the same things that
Danny did you and you're saying that
you're doing it and you know it's wrong
yeah you have to stop so that's one set
you have to think mother fix yourself
and sometimes fixing yourself means
don't be looking for somebody to love
because you got a big stairs together
it's broke and it's hurt you have to
find a way if it means opening a Bible
or Koran of Torah
men just looking up at the stars doing
something you have to dig stand inside
them so you got to you got to know the
difference and you have to be honest you
know can be true sometimes the truth
hurts truth is over and it took always
hers that the truth you know what hurts
the truth ain't growth
what's something that you think that I
should know as a father
oh good question what you should know
you'll be fathering your child your
daughter for the rest of your life
that means that when she gets 50 you're
gonna be daddy but you also have to
understand that and she's young now
she's gonna grow into who she's gonna be
enjoy the moment every moment you have
with a child I'll enjoy you know I'm
saying because I promise you one day
you're gonna sit back and say I remember
me and it's gonna be those two moments
that you cherish
another thing you have to do is you have
to remember that you are raising no
matter what black children and being a
black male you have to understand that
this strikes already gonna be throwing
error yeah and and she has to know that
and you have to be there to protect her
protect the hurts mean and make sure she
has this make sure she has this you know
because anybody could run off no hands
but who who has this to think I will do
thank you so much mr. Harris man you
gave me gave me some gems today man I'm
taking notes over here you got like this
real like calm or about like the young
foot we say unbothered you know like I'm
just trying to get the way you rap like
that place yet I enjoy that like us
young dudes are working to be right
there this has been a very heartwarming
and joyful experience to see the future
I think it's beautiful I think this is
the start of tearing down some of the
stereotypes and I hope nothing but the
best of all if you enjoyed watching the
conversations I have
and you want to learn a little bit more
about me please visit my channel ask the
birthday
everybody's locals you know and don't
let the word black scared because ask
the father what a nasty day I will take
and to all you father's out there and
all you're expecting father's / master
black dad
[Music]